the oceans are magnificent and huge but
certainly not forever especially the way
we are fishing we are running out of
fish and the reason is simple we've been
taking them out of the water faster than
nature can do it in fact at the pace
were going the oceans could be out of
fish by 2050 in recent decades we've
stopped getting many of the fish we eat
from the ocean and started raising them
in fish farms there's a problem to feed
our farmed fish we've been going back to
the oceans to plot huge quantities of
smaller species called forage fish
sardines anchovies they go out with big
nets bring them in and grind them up and
take the oil out and it becomes an
animal feed but there is limited supply
of forage fish in the world
many forage fish populations are already
at dangerously low levels without their
food source most fish farms will cease
to function and fish could be off the
menu
this is an issue of common sense there's
a problem and there's an obvious
solution we're at the forefront of
finding a different ways to raise fish
in the world of aquaculture bill and his
colleagues at 2 by sea are working on an
idea they hope will help out the planet
and ensure that fish farming has a
future so this is where you store the
food this is the palace yes what does it
mean that that is made out of algae
pistachio pistachio oil pistachio beale
corn flax flax oil flax meal they've
developed the first completely
vegetarian fish feed to be used
commercially in the US we're
specifically trying to keep away from
using the ocean as an a unlimited
resource for free fish the cheapest
possible way to put a pellet together
has been to use the ocean what was
considered an unlimited amount of free
fish but it's not unlimited it's
extremely limited and we're finding out
just how limit it now so the goal we had
set was to get rid of fish meal and fish
oil completely from the diet of our farm
fish how you do that was a little more
difficult quick search on internet it
kind of came up with a few papers one is
my doctor Ric barrows at USDA
I've always liked fish I've got a trout
pond at home a trout stream 300 gallon
marine aquarium I'm kind of a fish freak
but I call it passionate some people
call it obsessive bill Fox called me and
asked about fish meal free diets
plant-based diets and I said yeah I have
one fish nutritionist for the last
thirty years have been looking for
replacements for fish meal we do know
that we can totally eliminate fish meal
from fish diets and still have a healthy
fast growing fish here's some of the
containers that all the ingredients we
use in some of the diets one of the
first things the Ric Flair has ever told
me was that fish don't need ingredients
fish need nutrition they don't need fish
meal but they need is an intelligent
balanced set of ingredients that
formulate a perfect protein the right
amount of carbohydrates the right
that's we've evaluated fish meal free
feeds with eight species most of
considered carnivorous but I don't
really think we're turning a carnivorous
fish into a herbivore what I think we're
doing is taking soybeans and corn and
algae and turning that into meat we're
really not changing the animal we're
just changing what they consume oh wow
you can see they hate it ya know they're
obviously not interested in it at all
you realize what a technique it is to
make a pellet float instead of sink
uh-huh that is truly a fine art the two
by C guys they're very happy with the
way the fish have been performing on the
feed the product they're producing I
understand is well accepted by the chefs
in San Francisco the colors right the
texture is right from a health
standpoint that's really enriched I make
it threes it tastes like what it should
be like a like a wild fish I'm just a
big fan and I think I foresee this as a
future in sustainable fishery
there is a downside to all of this the
plant bases fee had cost about twice as
much as conventional feed that's a
barrier to wider adoption of the 2 by C
diet at least for net but if wild fish
populations continue to decline it won't
be long before going vegetarian is the
only option
we have been treating the ocean and the
seemingly limitless supply of free fish
as a given if we don't have a backup
solution there's gonna be a whole lot of
hungry people